the daily wire editor-in-chief ben
shapiro he's also the host of the
brand-new fox news special the ben
shapiro
election special and that premieres this
Sunday at 8 p.m. Eastern 5 in the West
bed and welcome back thanks radley so
obviously there are not just senators on
the Judiciary Committee eager to hear
from dr. Ford but voters very curious to
see how the court is going to shape up
before they cast votes in the midterms
what do you make of these developments
tonight you know it's hard to tell where
exactly this is going all that it seems
to me is that a lot of the requests that
are being put forward by it by Ford seem
kind of unreasonable if for example we
are hearing that Ford wants to testify
after Cavanaugh which makes no sense I
mean you actually have to have the
accuser testify before you can testify
to Roebuck the accuser you've never
heard of a trial where the defendant
actually testifies before the plaintiff
that doesn't make a lot of sense
you you're we also don't know what the
date is going to be on this thing it
seems to me that this is all delay
tactic I'll be very curious to see
obviously whether it actually happens is
gonna be private or is it gonna be
public Republicans are being it seems to
me quite forthcoming about allowing for
basically whatever she wants in order to
testify said as much in their letter
they said that they appreciate that the
committee has been reasonable and
accommodating to dr. Ford's requests
yeah and if the Republicans continue to
be reasonable and accommodating and Ford
simply doesn't testify at that point you
have to assume that a lot of this was a
political ploy again what's so
frustrating about this is that I think
good-hearted people on all sides of the
aisle would like to know whether this is
a lie or whether it's the truth or
whether it's misremembering I think the
guilt or innocence is what's the key
issue here but because of all of the
political manipulation primarily by
Democrats surrounding this particular
issue it's very difficult to get beyond
the partisan hackery it's it's difficult
to get beyond the feeling the Democrats
don't really care very much about
establishing guilt or innocence in this
case that this is really just a club
with which to beat Brett cab not and
hopefully to win additional votes in the
2018 election unfortunately that's how
part of this appears to be shaping up
because you know these are serious
allegations with very serious
ramifications and what I'm curious about
and I know that you are in fact a lawyer
what do you think Republicans on the
Senate Judiciary Committee should do as
far as a lawyer potentially questioning
dr. Ford and you know maybe a female
defense attorney who can take her story
apart a little bit I mean that makes
perfect sense to me that we have
something similar with regards to Anita
Hill and Clarence Thomas it doesn't seem
to make a lot of sense to have a bunch
of senators who don't know much about
the case in the first place
questioning I mean if she's not going to
be allowed normally in a court of law
you are allowed to face down your
accuser this this ridiculous notion that
you're never allowed to face down your
accuser because of the shame of the of
the accusation this obviously would not
hold in a criminal trial which this
effectively has now become I mean Brett
Kavanaugh his life is either over or
he's down the Supreme Court right one of
two things is going to happen here and
that being the case he's not allowed to
face down his accuser it seems to me
that having somebody there who actually
knows Brett Kavanaugh story and can
represent that story from his defense
point of view would be smart politics by
the Republicans as well as a just thing
to do apparently for doesn't want that
which makes perfect sense you don't want
to be asked tired of questions even if
you're telling the truth so it's it's a
really ugly sticky situation and all of
this could have been avoided if Dianne
Feinstein had reported this stuff as
soon as she heard it and if she'd worked
with Republicans to create an actual
process here as opposed to everybody
just catching his catch-can yeah
absolutely and you know she also could
have trusted the FBI a little bit more
because I think that's what Democrats
have been claiming to want all along is
to re-instill confidence in these
institutions and the FBI would have kept
all of the secret and perhaps maybe
conducted their investigation a little
bit differently it doesn't really sound
like that from their point of view but I
know that there are Democrats that are
also questioning senator Feinstein's
motives here and it's really upset about
how all of this has played out because
it this has really turned into a worst
case scenario for her as well it's a
fiasco in the most ironic thing about
the fiasco is that you remember there
was one Zion Feinstein who's running for
the Senate in 1992 after the Clarence
Thomas hearings and one of her key
critiques of her fellow Democrats was
that they handled the Anita Hill
hearings wrong they handedly you need a
hill Henri's by the way almost exactly
the way they occurred they're currently
handling this under the auspices of
Dianne Feinstein so it again looks like
a political manipulation which is really
tragic I think for everybody because
again the vast majority of people across
the aisle Republicans and Democrats
really only care whether the accusation
is true they're not as interested in
democratic attempts to delay this beyond
the election or use it as a cudgel to
win votes yeah I don't understand
there's no physical evidence to gather
right now and from the people that we've
heard who were supposedly also at the
party they've got no desire to
corroborate or testify so you know and
and and lesson I've said this the last
three nights we've seen so many sexual
harassment cases and we've seen once one
accuser comes forward it either jostles
the memories of past victims or they
feel emboldened and not alone and and
they come out and they basically
establish a pattern we have yet to see
that for Brett Kavanaugh and you know it
is right if he did it it's super gross
and it's wrong and he can't tonight and
he should answer for it if he didn't do
it
how does he clear his name then that
really is the question we've seen it no
corroborating evidence none the first
time this story was ever told to anybody
who wasn't her husband was to
psychiatrists 30 years after the fact we
have no contemporaneous accounts we have
no actual evidence that anybody heard
about it at the time we have no actual
evidence that anybody who witnessed an
event was actually there or it can
corroborate her account of the events we
have no date we have no time we have no
location on the basis of that we're
supposed to say that this guy not only
should lose his seat on the Supreme
Court but probably lose his career on
the DC Circuit Court of Appeals on the
basis of that yeah it's a some brutal
and harsh realities here that we're
going to face head-on next week Ben
Shapiro thanks so much hey thanks a lot
good luck with your special